Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are talking about our
top 12 creative influences.
Now we've done top 10 episodes
where it's like top 10 favorite films
or top 10 favorite whatever.
We've done top 10.
Game show television shows.
We've had this one on the list of things
to do for a while,
but I think we've both been
a little bit intimidated
and the process by which
I kinda got into this
only confirmed my intimidation.
So much so that literally 10 minutes ago,
I was like, "Dude, we gotta make this 12
because I just feel like
I'm selling people short.
I don't know how I feel about the 12.
I don't know how I feel about the order.
I just, I feel."
Well, you know what, Rhett?
Almost creatively crippled
right now.
You know what?
Hey, let's take a deep breath
and let's just, let's shed that.
This is just a construct for
us to have a conversation about
This is good.
The people that we believe-
Putting me
in the right frame of mind.
They've entered our psyche.
They've impacted us to various degrees
that then it has made its way into the,
it's permeated us to then come
out in our own creativity.
And yeah, it's quite an
exercise to connect those dots,
but let's just say these
are not definitive lists.
Let's also say that I
know that I forgot people.
Oh yeah, and-
But none of them
are listening.
And part of that's gonna
probably come when you've
got somebody on your list
and I'm like, "Aw dang."
Hopefully we, yeah.
We don't know each other's list.
I've got 15 honorable mentions
that I'll mention at the end.
We have not-
Just in case.
Seen each other's list.
We're gonna alternate starting with 12.
I'll go with 12.
And we're gonna do the
traditional method which is,
'cause I'm assuming
there's some crossover,
that if a person says, "My
number 12 is blankety blank,"
and then the other guy's like,
"My number two is blankety blank."
Then you gotta talk about-
The person who's higher
goes first in talking about it.
Oh.
The person who ranks that person higher
gets to talk about them first.
But they have to talk about them earlier
than they were ready to.
Right, so it's a little
bit of a compromise.
So you have to do something
you don't wanna do.
And I'll say that moreso than other lists,
and it's always been tough,
that the actual ranking
is much more arbitrary.
The ranking could be upside
down as far as I'm concerned.
Really all the way to the top
because how do you measure these things?
Yeah, it's how you evaluate
it, which we can get into.
I think we'll get into those specifics
as we roll these people out.
Yeah, there's a difference
between inspiration
and influence too.
And so depending on the person,
sometimes there's a direct connection
with something that I experienced
or learned from a person
that then directly impacted
something from our career.
Other times it's just kind
of the idea of their approach
or the way that it made me feel.
It's much more nebulous in general.
So it's kind of
all over the place.
Agreed.
Well, last thing I'll say-
That's true of creativity.
Yeah, well, last thing I'll say
before we break into the list
is that this is not an uncommon
question in interviews,
like who are your biggest
creative influences?
And I think that we've always had this,
or I feel like I've had this,
I don't wanna speak for you,
I've had this sense that like,
I don't, like I'm not
formally trained in anything.
I went to Harnett County public schools.
I didn't do anything creative in training.
I went to engineering school.
I always get this weird feeling
and super high imposter syndrome
when you start talking
about creative influences
because I don't have
a creative background.
I've just lived and breathed
creativity my entire life.
And so I don't know what
to say in those situations,
but when I really dug down
and started going back
to the beginning of like,
when did you start thinking
about creative things?
I started realizing that
there's a lot of people
who have influenced me.
Well, we have influences.
But no, and I don't wanna say like,
"Oh, I don't have influences."
I'm just saying that I get
intimidated by the question.
And then even when we
said we were gonna do 10,
I was saying maybe we should do five.
And now I've talked you into doing 12
and I've got 15 honorable mentions.
It's just a weird process.
I'm excited to talk about it though.
I do not want you to mention
your honorable mentions
because they may be my list.
No, no, no.
If you say somebody who's
on my honorable mentions,
only at that point, will I be like,
"Ah, they made honorable mention."
I'm not gonna say that until to the end.
Whenever I would get that
question of creative influences,
because it's so hard to nail it down
and without a prepared
answer or doing the exercise
that we've only started
to do for this episode,
I would fall back on,
I'm not a student of a
lot of the things we do.
A lot of what we do is kind of like
we are among the group of people
that invented it, honestly.
So there hasn't been people in
like the world of creatordom,
if you could call it, to
emulate, that went ahead of us.
'Cause it didn't exist ahead of us,
so if you look at it that way.
And I always thought of that as an asset.
It's like, okay, this sets
us up to be more original
and more ourselves
and people can emulate us if they want to.
But really it was,
I think part of it was just
being intimidated by the work
that we started to do.
Who wants to start? You
wanna start with number 12?
Sure.
I'm going to start, I put
this person at number 12
because I felt like putting
them at any number was weird.
And if they either had to be
at number 12 or number one,
then I put them at number 12
because he's likely to understand.
My dad. Okay?
So I just started with-
Jimmy.
My dad
as a creative influence.
Okay, cool, cool.
Now I've said this quite a bit about how-
I totally get it.
My sense of humor is largely informed
by the way my dad's his sense of humor is.
And the things that he thinks are funny
and the way that he interjects
himself into a conversation,
the way that he, once he
sort of has an audience,
the way that he would begin
to entertain that audience.
I've said forever that
if I wasn't a comedian,
I would be a professor.
Well, that's what my dad was
for his entire life, basically,
starting in like 1980.
So he had an audience.
He had an audience every single day.
My observation, because I definitely think
he's also a comedic influence on me.
Like I can, even to this day,
you'll make a joke and I'll be
like, "That's a Jimmy joke."
Oh yeah.
And it's like, if it's dry and a little...
I want, let's see, how do you describe it?
It's-
Dry.
Like not derogatory or judgy,
but it's observational.
And it might,
sometimes it might be kind
of like in good spirits
making fun of something or somebody.
There's a bit of that.
And there's a confidence in it.
There's a confidence.
There's a confidence in his-
There's a swagger in it.
In his humor.
He was good in small groups.
Like, I mean a classroom is
an awkward size if you're...
Like, I've never been a standup
comedian, but if you are,
it's like, when you're
speaking to a big room
or an arena even,
when you go bigger,
it's a different thing.
But when a room gets too small,
it's like you're talking to people
in like a doctor's waiting room.
It's like, that's intimidating.
Like for us to be behind
a desk on GMM and to know
that there's a million
people watching every day,
you just kind of get over it.
First of all, they're not
there. It's just a lens.
But second of all,
that's different than
even my experience now.
If I'm in like a hangout
and like you're telling a story,
and then all of a sudden,
it's just like-
Yeah, I don't like those.
The eight people are
listening to your story.
That's a different vibe.
It kind of puts you in a different spot.
But your dad is good in those situations.
He is good,
but I think the thing that
I've really taken from him
is that 'cause I'm not very comfortable
in those sort of small
and medium size groups.
Now, I can be, and I can then go into my,
but I have to kind of shift from-
It's a mindset.
Personal Rhett to Entertainer Rhett.
'Cause a lot of people
might think, "Oh, I bet you,
when Rhett and Link are
hanging out with their friends,
they're just funny, funny, funny."
It's not true. It's just not true.
Partly because it's a
profession in some sense,
but there's also a power dynamic
that comes with being
recognized as the person
who's currently has the
power to speak to a crowd.
So a professor has that,
a comedian has that,
they have the microphone.
I tend to, that's where I'm at my best
is when I have the power.
Not in a negative sense,
but when it's just like,
"All right, monkey, dance."
That's when I do well.
But if it's just like,
everybody's just kind
of being personal person
in this situation
and now are you gonna say something funny?
You're right, my dad
is really good at that.
He's good with the quips.
He wasn't as much of a storyteller
or there's all types of
genres of funny people.
He does have some really funny stories.
He's got some funny stories.
Well, I haven't heard as much of those.
It's more of like the one liners.
Someone else is talking
and then he'll lean over
and say something to you,
like give you a little private commentary.
And he also has things like,
I don't remember exactly what
he said, but I'll paraphrase.
Like getting on an elevator
at like a tourist attraction.
Like okay, 15 people get on
an elevator to go to the top
of the Empire State
Building or whatever, right?
And so you're with a bunch of strangers
and everybody's, no one talks, right?
So like one minute into an elevator ride,
my dad will be like, "So how
is everybody doing today?"
It's like, he'll do
something to break the ice
when he senses that there's
an awkward situation.
But he's not one of those,
some people may do that
because they're friendly
and they're outgoing.
He's doing it because the
choice to do it is funny.
Oh yeah, definitely.
But he is friendly and outgoing,
but that's not why he's-
Yeah, he's friendly,
but the main reason he's doing it
is 'cause doing this now is funny.
So as I think about just
obviously genetic influences,
but also environmental
influences in the way that I,
and the things that I think are funny
is so largely influenced
by him genetically
and the way that he behaved growing up,
that I gotta put him on the list.
And it probably makes sense
for him to be number one
since he's like 50% of my DNA.
But it's like, I just put him on the list-
No, he's your dad.
Just so he's on the list.
He influenced you in a lot of ways.
He's not an entertainer.
But like the comedy, it was just,
it sprinkles in and it
comes out occasionally.
Like if one of us is gonna be
the one to make the dry quip,
it's absolutely gonna be you
and you can trace that to your dad.
The one liner and the like your
dad didn't raise an eyebrow,
but he kinda, it was that same effect.
My number 12,
I'm hoping to surprise you
with this one with a "Oh yes!"
'Cause that's how I felt
when I actually thought of this one.
Ross McElwee.
Ross McElwee is-
Oh, you put him on your list?
Number five for me.
Oh man. I thought you would've
forgotten him entirely.
I got you.
Not only is Ross McElwee my number five-
You got me.
But my rec today comes from Ross McElwee.
Okay, well let me help you out
with just kinda giving
some background on the guy.
He's a documentary filmmaker
from the '80s and on.
He was first famous for "Sherman's March."
The longer title is
"Sherman's March: A Meditation
on the Possibility of
Romantic Love In the South
During an Era of Nuclear
Weapons Proliferation."
You're really sealing my
thunder. That's my rec, man.
Well, I have to give them
context for who this guy is.
He also released an
autobiographical documentary in 1993
called "Time Indefinite."
So I'll let you, why
did you put him so high?
'Cause yeah, I could
have put him there too.
Set the scene.
When we watched that first
film, "Sherman's March,"
I remember thinking-
Well, where were we?
Do you remember when in our
life we were watching it?
It was like right after college.
It was, I'm pretty sure it was in context
of starting to make our own documentary,
"Looking for Ms. Locklear."
I think it was the thing
that led us to do it.
Definitely.
But I don't think we made the decision
to do it and then watch it.
We kept referring back to it
'cause we were getting
into documentary film.
The thing that we like so much
that I really connected
with so much about this guy
is that he made documentaries
that were incredibly vulnerable,
personally vulnerable.
They were really a personal exercise in,
it was self exploration and self-discovery
through the lens of other people, right?
And so-
He was the main character
in his documentaries.
I call it self-insertion.
Self-insertion documentary,
which is not a great term.
Which again is exactly what we did
with "Looking for Ms.
Locklear" way back in the day.
Also think "Supersize Me."
Yeah, the thing that I
love so much about it
is I'm really drawn
towards documentary film
where the thing that's on
display is the people first,
not a subject
or an agenda or a cause.
Now I like like political documentaries
and I like documentaries
that all of a sudden change
the way that you think
about the environment, I like those.
Humanity on display, I totally agree.
But it's about the
people and that's why I,
now I didn't put Errol Morris on my list.
He was an honorable mention.
I love Errol Morris for
the same exact reason,
but Ross McElwee is the one
that we first connected with.
And then the way that he-
Well, he's from North Carolina.
Yeah, it was so relatable.
There was another film, "Bright Leaves,"
which is about his connection to like the,
his family's connection
to the tobacco industry in North Carolina.
So we had this connection
and we definitely were referring to it
and were actively inspired
by what he did in 1986 and on
when we were in 2003 making
"Looking for Ms. Locklear."
And not just "Looking for Ms. Locklear,"
but I would say the entire
"Commercial Kings" series,
all of our "I Love Local Commercials."
It was based on that same principle,
we just love people
and we love people who've
never been on camera,
are not prepared to be on camera.
And actually one of the things
that I am most sort of
creatively restless about
over the past 10 years has been the fact
that we haven't been
able to get back to that.
Yeah, I'll go one step further
than just "Commercial Kings"
and say, again, we were making,
it was 2003 when we were filming
"Looking for Ms. Locklear."
Didn't come out til 2006.
So this is like pre-YouTube, pre-vlogging
really taking hold in any meaningful way.
So the fact that he was
autobiographical, vulnerable,
it was putting his story out there,
but he was the guy controlling the camera.
He would set the camera down.
Then he would walk out and
he would be in front of it
and he would,
there would be different
scenes that he would set up.
We emulated that directly in
"Looking for Ms. Locklear."
But this is a, it's a vlog
precursor in a lot of ways.
And so it was more artistic.
And even though we never,
I mean, we were very late
and hesitant to vlogging,
we had this seed planted from
this era in our creativity
that gave us an appetite
to connect directly with our audience
and not just create things
for an audience to enjoy separate from us.
So that's why I think he's so important.
But not, I mean,
not as important as I
thought he was though.
Yeah, again, it was, I just put him on,
I had to put him somewhere.
All right, what's your 11?
My 11 is, maybe this'll
surprise you, C. S. Lewis.
Okay. All right, I get it.
For you, especially.
I'll keep this one relatively short.
So C. S. Lewis, of course,
he's famously known as
like a Christian theologian
and an author.
But the thing that I really
connected with him about
was "The Chronicles of Narnia,"
which not a huge fan of the
movies, let me just say that.
I'm definitely a "Lord of the Rings" guy
when it comes to the movies.
And ultimately in adulthood,
the books of "Lord of the Rings," but-
It's crazy that they were
like really close friends.
They were contemporaries, yeah.
J. R. R. Tolkien.
I've been to the bar where they,
I've been to the bar next to Oxford
where they would hang out.
I remember, you told me.
So the thing about C. S. Lewis
is it's the first fantasy
literature that I ever read.
And it's so approachable.
It's so easy to read it as
like a 8, 9, 10 year old.
And I consumed "The Chronicles
of Narnia" voraciously
at like the age of 10
and just fell in love with these stories.
I mean, you can read, I mean-
It was your Harry Potter 'cause
there wasn't a Harry Potter.
You can read them
and you can also read them
in like a couple of nights.
They're so much shorter.
And the thing that I love about
"The Chronicles of Narnia"
is it starts in the real world,
and this is true of much fantasy,
but it starts in the real world
and then there is a wardrobe
that gets you into the fantasy world.
And that is a concept
that I've never been,
it just it's like it went into my soul
and connected with me
on this cosmic level.
And I am so intrigued by any story
that follows this convention.
We're starting in the real world
and there is a pathway to another place.
Any movie that does that and does it well,
I'm all in the whole time, right?
It's one of the reasons
that I don't think that
my soul connects with-
I don't know why the first
thing I thought about
was "Being John Malkovich," but go ahead.
But it's also I like secret rooms
and it's the reason that
we put that weird locker
in the first season of "Buddy System."
It's like, "Oh, what if we opened a locker
and had a secret bike in there."
I love that convention and
love to put it in things, but-
Also our novel, "The Lost
Causes of Bleak Creek."
I mean you go-
Same thing, yeah.
You've absolutely got that in the creek.
And so that way of
thinking about the world
and way of thinking about-
Portals.
Taking what is possible or
taking what is impossible
and bringing it into the
possible sort of tangible world
is something that it permeates
the way that I think about story.
And that comes from C. S. Lewis.
I mean, that was the first.
It was in me already, right?
But he's the one who brought
it out and it was like,
"Oh, there's a whole world,
there's a whole life.
There's all these possibilities
that exist in this world
that you can get through."
And as a kid,
many, many times I would be
walking through the woods
and I would see like a tree
that had like a hole in it.
And I would be like,
"Okay, is that my Narnia?"
And I would pray,
"God, if this is Narnia, let me in."
Like I wanted to be in it so bad.
Pray to God.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, 'cause that
was my way of thinking.
You pray to Aslan?
And so C. S. Lewis.
I don't wanna say anything else
'cause we got a lot to get through.
My number 11. Can I
surprise you with this one?
Robert Rodriguez.
Okay. He was on the list
and I knocked him off.
Okay.
He's an honorable mission.
All right, whatever.
It was tough.
That was tough.
Robert Rodriguez, film director, producer.
Early films are "Desperado."
Antonio Banderas and Salma Hayek.
Really good movie. Super cool.
"From Dusk till Dawn,"
"Spy Kids," "Sin City."
I mean, he's even, I hesitate to mention,
he directed many episodes
of "The Book of Boba Fett."
One episode of "The Mandalorian."
Because of his, like,
his Robert Rodriguez take
on like with the Western gun slinger vibe,
made him a great choice for that.
Even though he's getting a lot of backlash
for "The Book of Boba
Fett" being kind of tepid.
I'm not gonna go there.
But back in 1992,
his first film called "El Mariachi"
was just a homemade Western,
but like a gangster Western,
like a guy was carrying
a guitar case with a...
Am I getting this
confused with "Desperado"?
He had a guitar case-
No that's "Mariachi."
That then he opened it up and it had this,
it had a gun in it.
It's been a long time since I've seen it.
But we discovered him in the
context of Quentin Tarantino,
who maybe is on your list,
but I actually replaced Tarantino
with Robert Rodriguez on my list
because he wrote a book in 1995-
"Rebel Without a Cause."
Which we read,
"Rebel Without a Crew."
And he basically chronicled
making "El Mariachi."
I mean it has this really
homemade feel to it.
But he shot it on film and
he like did it all himself.
He did not have a crew. And he
like didn't even have actors.
He had these friends
and like acquaintances
and pulling favors
to like make this epic,
super cool vibe, violent movie
that you could tell he made it himself,
but the conception and the
creativity involved in it,
just it overrode the
homemade nature of it.
And like, you could definitely tell
this guy was a tremendous talent.
And given the landscape of
entertainment at the time,
I believe he got a lot of attention
if not won awards at Sundance.
I don't know the details.
Yeah, that book was
transformational for us.
Again, he was on the list and I, yeah.
I mean, it was like 1995, 1996.
Like we're in high school.
We're like talking about
going to film school.
I didn't read it when
it came out, I remember-
You don't think we read it in high school?
I remember reading that after college.
After college?
That's when I read it.
So you may have read it
earlier. I read it after.
I just remember reading
that book and thinking,
and first of all, we've always been like
if we've got an idea,
we're gonna find a way to make it happen.
And you connect with people
who think that same way.
And we always felt like outsiders.
He scrapped everything together.
We weren't like living in Hollywood.
We weren't doing the traditional thing
of like becoming a PA
and working your way up
and then meeting the director one day,
we were just a couple of
guys in North Carolina.
And then you see this
guy who's writing about
just do it, just make it.
If you wanna make it
happen, make it happen.
And there's a couple of
principles in that book
that really stuck with me.
The one that we repeat time and time again
is whenever you're working on a project
and a film is the most applicable one,
but after you get the footage,
cut the trailer first.
Oh yeah, that's where we got that.
Once you've cut the footage
or once you've gathered the footage,
cut the trailer first
because the trailer gives you this vision
that you can look forward to.
You create a trailer that has the vibe
that you want the film to have.
And it gives you this true
north to look at because
you're gonna lose heart.
It makes it real.
Especially if you're
doing it all on your own.
I mean, this dude was scoring
his own films as well.
He was literally doing the score
to everything back in the day.
So yeah, we did that for
"Looking for Ms. Locklear."
And then you also can show
that trailer to people
and they get excited and it helps you.
It's a way to get financing.
Keep going.
So yeah, there was a lot to
learn there from that book.
We took a lot of inspiration,
but it was once we were
making our documentary,
we were filmmakers.
We were filmmakers. We
entered it in film festivals.
We won some awards.
Got shown on PBS, man.
Got shown on PBS in South Carolina.
Hey, I'll take it. I'll take that.
The under belly of North Carolina.
I'll take a Carolina.
Yeah, but we could apply
that label to ourselves
and we could say we've
done it and we're doing it.
I mean, we were on Campus
Crusade still at the time.
We were also that.
But it's like, "Hey, we have
a film, so we are filmmakers.
We are achieving the dream."
And he gave us a confidence to do that.
And you know, Daniel, the Smosh CEO,
his previous job was working
very closely with Robert.
And so maybe we'll have an
opportunity to meet him.
We could, I'm sure we could.
Sometime in the future.
Yeah, he was working at El Rey.
Be great to shake his
hand. Tell him thank you.
Okay, we've got 10 more each, but first-
Oh, this is-
What are we promoting right
now, Daniel? I can't remember.
TT2 now and forever.
Yeah, okay.
We still want people to
listen to Trevor's podcast?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're
still talking about Trevor.
What if they're gonna
listen to his podcast
instead of our podcast?
I mean-
What if they get hooked on this?
I don't care.
And then they don't have room for two.
That'd be fine.
That is fine.
Yeah, I mean,
it's still a Mythical podcast.
You might like Trevor
better than us.
And if you do, there ain't
nothing wrong with that.
That's a good thing, that's a good thing.
"Trevor Talks Too Much," check it out.
It's also on YouTube,
so you can listen to it with your eyes.
"Trevor Talks Too Much."
We need to pick up our pace.
Yeah, yeah. I'm gonna
move through a couple.
Well, I'm gonna move through
this one pretty fast.
I've got some faster ones.
Number 10, Dolly Parton.
My number 10 is Dolly Parton.
Hey, we're all happy!
And we only did this because of Jenna.
And Jenna's in there.
No we didn't, but she
might be your number one.
I dunno, is she gonna
be on your list, Jenna?
She'd be my number one.
She's Jenna's number one.
Yeah, and the numbers are arbitrary.
So we're neck and neck here. Go ahead.
Okay, so I don't consider myself
a long-time Dolly Parton fan
in terms of when I was listening
to Merle back in the day,
even when I heard that he had
written some songs about her,
like "Always Wanting You" was
supposedly written about her.
"Always wanting you,
but never having you."
Yeah, he had a big crush on her.
I always was when I would
hear Dolly Parton song,
I would be like, "Oh,
that's a great song."
And I was obviously attracted to her.
But it wasn't actually until
"Dolly Parton's America," the podcast,
was that a Radiolab production?
Is that what that was?
Yeah.
That was probably last
year or the year before.
And it was, it's just
an incredible podcast.
And I began to really understand
how much of her story I identified with.
Now I don't come from the
mountains of Tennessee,
but I come from the
plains of North Carolina.
Plains.
The idea of being someone who,
because of where you're from,
there's not a lot expected of you.
And you kinda feel like every
time you come into a room,
you are bringing that
expectation with you.
Now she exemplifies that in a huge way
because people thought that,
"Oh, this is this little country bumpkin."
And she was like, "No, no, no,
I'm not just some country bumpkin.
I'm an incredible musician.
I'm an incredible songwriter.
And I'm an incredible businesswoman
and I'm gonna have an amusement park
and I'm gonna have this
place where you can eat
while people are on horseback."
And not just that,
but she is an incredible humanitarian
who has found a way to be very vocal
about marginalized people
and very inclusive as a personal
brand, without alienating,
which is very difficult to do.
She's alienated a number of people
on the right at this point,
just because she's standing
up for marginalized people,
but she's found a way to
maintain a very broad audience
in a way that is unifying people
in what can be a very, is super
divisive right now, right?
Yeah, and we seek to do that.
I mean, to sum it up,
it's a brand ethos built
around her true self.
I think that's how I summarize
the creative inspiration.
Number nine for me is iJustine.
Oh wow.
Yeah.
I have a creator on my list
that's not iJustine. Okay.
Of course we're friends with Justine.
We're not in constant contact,
but we'll go a long time without talking.
But she was probably
sponsored by Constant Contact
at some point.
Yeah, that's true.
And so were we.
We came up together on the internet,
but she was ahead of us.
And I think she was
tremendously influential
in that she embraced
cutting edge technology
to set herself apart.
And we noticed that.
It was when this website JustineTV
started making it possible
for you to live stream.
She was one of the first people to say,
"I'm gonna live stream my life 24/7."
I don't know how long she did it,
but it was, I mean, it
might have, it was at least-
It was a year.
It was at least weeks. Somewhere
between weeks and years.
I don't remember that part.
But I remember watching her
go about her life as a student
of what we were coining the
phrase as internetainment.
Okay, can this, is this even
possible? Is this a good idea?
We didn't know the answer. We
found it out by watching her.
She didn't know the answer.
She found out by doing it.
And she set herself apart.
She got that edge by
being on the cutting edge.
And it was something that
we adopted as a strategy.
And I think that directly led to us doing
the RhettandLinKast Live, so-
Pretty definitely.
We partnered with Ustream,
she was also on Ustream,
and we did a live internet
broadcast every Thursday night
from our basement studio in Lillington.
Which is the precursor to GMM.
Yeah, that is what became
"Good Mythical Morning."
We talk a lot about "Good
Morning Chia Lincoln"
as being the precursor to
"Good Mythical Morning."
But two guys at one
desk and one microphone,
that was RhettandLinKast.
Yeah, absolutely.
That's where it started as a genre for us.
And it was live for an
hour for an entire year.
And those archives live exclusively
on the Mythical Society.
Weekly.
Weekly, if you wanna see them.
They're on the Mythical Society.
But that's where we-
We compared notes too.
We developed our chops
of the conversation
that are reflecting in
what we're doing right now,
what we do on "Good Mythical Morning"
behind the desk every day.
And we didn't have a lot of people
to compare notes with at the time,
and she was one of the few that was,
that we reached out to and
talked to and learned a lot from.
I've got a creator on my list
as well, for similar reasons,
a little higher up.
Number nine for me, Jordan Peele.
So it's interesting,
Jordan is a huge influence on two levels.
The first is just very simply
before he was the Jordan
Peele that you know,
when he was just the Jordan
Peele of Key and Peele, right?
Which you also knew.
Yeah.
It's arguably just as visible.
So I think there's three
aspects that I'll quickly cover.
The first is the fact that
just as a sketch comedian,
somebody making a sketch
that was connecting on the
internet in a huge way,
both Key and Peele, huge
inspirations for us.
We could only hope to get to be
a fraction as funny as
they are in their sketches,
and even getting to a fraction of that
would be an accomplishment.
The second thing of course
is what he has accomplished
as a filmmaker,
which is just bringing
comedy and horror together,
horror, comedy, and
social commentary together
in a way that's not cheesy at all.
No one is doing it. People
are trying to emulate it.
No one has emulated it yet.
And when he first did it, it was, I mean,
it was just, it floored you.
Because it was so good
right out of the gate.
And it was like, this is-
This guy's been sitting
on this the whole time?
Which is the third thing.
And for me, the most significant thing
is the transition from a sketch comedian
to a powerhouse filmmaker.
And producer.
In being in this town for the
past 11, going on 12 years,
by the time this comes out,
I think we'll have been in LA for 12 years
and it'll be our 12th anniversary here.
Being here for 12 years
and being someone who
is primarily recognized
as a YouTube person, a
YouTuber, a YouTube sensation,
you bring that into every room.
You bring that into every meeting.
And it's not a good, it's not a plus.
It's not a plus in this town
to be a YouTube sensation.
You come in with a bunch of baggage
that then you have to unpack
and explain who you aren't
and what you are capable of creatively.
And listen, we've been able
to do so many awesome things
and I'm very creatively fulfilled,
but a lot of the things
that I really want us
to be able to do,
the fact that we have a
YouTube presence is actually,
it works for you in
getting you in the room,
but works against you
once you're in the room.
And the fact that-
I think it's true
of entertainers in general that like-
They put you in boxes.
They put you in a box, no
matter what that box is,
it's really hard to get out of it.
And the fact that he got out of that box
in such a decisive-
And such an Oscar worthy way-
Successful way.
Look, again, I mean, that's
not gonna happen with us, okay?
I'm just gonna be, I'll just
go ahead and break the news
in case you wanna believe that.
We're not gonna just suddenly make a movie
that is going to blow the world away
and win a bunch of Oscars.
I mean, I would hope and
that's what we aspire to,
but chances are that's not gonna happen.
But just being able to
make that transition
in the way that he did
is so inspirational, almost
intimidatingly inspirational.
All right. I could have
put him on my list.
Number eight, I'ma go back.
I think I'm gonna steal your thunder here,
'cause I'm gonna stay in the
world of internetainment.
And I'm gonna say the
vlogbrothers, John and Hank Green.
My number eight. Hold on,
is this your number eight?
It's my number eight.
Okay, my number eight is
Hank and John as well.
So there we go. Putting
them up with Dolly.
You go first 'cause I just talked.
They're friends of us, of ours,
they know how much we respect them
and it's flattering that
they also respect us.
Again, with no one to
go ahead of any of us,
you cling to the people who
are holding on for dear life
and trying to build an
outpost on the frontier
of what's becoming the
future of entertainment.
And for them to have
a similar relationship as brothers.
We watched them closely
before we knew them.
They weren't in the same
room together usually.
But they had a connection
that was on display
that then they very overtly fostered
into a community.
They named their fans the Nerdfighters,
they developed an identity
that was bigger than the two of them
that they participated in.
Like a technical, digital community
of forums and interactions
through a tool called Ning at the time.
We're like, "We're just
gonna do what they did.
We're gonna create a Ning community."
We're gonna name, yes.
We're gonna name our fans.
We're gonna let them,
we're gonna empower
them to name themselves.
But we were gonna suggest Mythical Beasts.
Right, and then we're gonna
choose that one together.
Yeah, so the Mythical Beasts moniker
was a direct emulation
of their Nerdfighteria,
which then that becomes
the name of our company.
And so the branding shifting
beyond the two of us
is something that we got from them.
And also how entrepreneurial they are
in like starting VidCon
and like Hank starting his-
There was no endeavor that was off limits.
They're always doing something.
And then John and now Hank
having this sort of talent wrapped up
in being able to write
that they're kind of sitting on as well,
and then unleashing that in the world
in a really significant way that isn't,
they're being recognized
for their accomplishments,
not because they had a YouTube channel,
but because they're genuinely
talented at writing.
And again, that's just, that's
inspirational to me as well.
Number seven.
I feel bad not, I feel bad
putting this man on the list
in a place that isn't of preeminence,
but Merle Haggard is my number seven.
Now I-
My number seven
is Merle Haggard.
Oh really?
Yeah, I guess we're thinking
the same thing here.
It's crazy how this ended up happening.
And there's, okay, I'll
let you couch this one
because there's different,
this is a tough one.
Well, I'll just be honest with you.
There was a point in which
Merle was not on the list
because when I was thinking
about him, I was like-
We're not country music artists.
I absolutely love his music,
but from his creative influence,
what kind of creative
influence has he had?
Is that how I think about Merle?
Or just I think about this guy that just,
I love the way he does what he does.
But then I started realizing,
oh no, like I've sung...
And we talked about it.
We were recently on a ski
trip together with our boys.
We were coming back down,
well, actually, as we were
going up there, I think.
No, coming back down,
we listened to Merle,
a playlist that you put together.
Which I asked you to share with me
and you still haven't shared
it with me, by the way.
Yeah, I wanted you to ask me again.
But it's basically the best
Merle throughout the years,
which we pretty much agree
exactly on what that is.
And I just don't, I'm not
a guy who makes playlists
and so I need you to make them for me
so I can then enjoy them.
But in listening to that playlist,
one of the things you said
was this stuff is just,
so we listened to this so much
because we grew up in a different era.
We grew up in a time where you had tapes
and it was the tapes that
you had that you played.
And so it was like
building 10 Spotify playlists
and never departing from them
for like a 10-year period.
If you were to do that,
you think about the way that music
and the person behind that music
would seep into your bones.
You couldn't even shuffle it.
Yeah. Right.
And so the way, first of all,
the way that we sing is
heavily influenced by Merle.
Yeah, the way-
The way we think about melody
is heavily influenced by Merle Haggard.
And so that, and music is
a big part of what we do
and has been even a bigger
part of what we do in the past.
So it isn't that there's
something that Merle has done.
This is more of the indirect
influence sort of thing.
The like you're around
somebody and it seeps into,
and you know that it's influencing
the way you go about things.
I think I can make it
a little more direct.
I think that we would pick songs of his
and we would dissect them.
I think there was like an
art appreciation aspect to,
we would sit in the car,
we would pick it apart and
appreciate parts of it.
So we never had like
art appreciation classes
to really understand the
value of how art can move you.
It just wasn't an emphasis
of ours in high school,
but it was something that we
found ourselves doing impromptu
through his music.
And we would marvel at the subject matters
that he would choose to,
the pictures he would paint.
And how we would say things like,
"There's nobody else writing
songs like this on the radio."
There was an innovation in our minds.
There was a, it was unique.
And the choices that he was making,
the thing that we talk about a lot is-
It was self-expression.
Well, in the way that-
It was different.
In the way that he brought,
like when he gets into
the late '70s, early '80s,
which is our favorite era.
And just, and I'm also,
I'm beginning to say era instead
of era, just so you know.
Okay, you sound, I guess, smarter.
Just because era sounds like
you might be saying error, error.
Era, okay do it.
So era,
just so you know.
All right.
I think it's like the official
New York Times pronunciation.
I don't know.
How did Merle say it?
Era.
No, no he didn't.
So the thing that he was doing at the time
is the choices he was making
musically with instrumentation,
the fact that he was like bringing in
this jazz influence outta nowhere
and all of a sudden there was
a saxophone in country music
and no one was doing that kind of thing.
It wasn't like when you listen to music
and you're just like,
"I just like the way this makes me feel,
and this is just a cool vibe."
It was that, but then it
was just like, oh man,
this was an exercise in curation
when he was making these songs.
The way that he brought these
specific people together
to make this specific
sound and you just let...
Just the other day when we were
listening to that playlist,
I was just reminded, I'm
like, "No one has done this."
The singularity of his voice.
The way he's done it.
And how we could study
its development,
helped us understand the
identity of an artist.
You know what, I wanna take an aside in,
on the ski trip coming back.
I had made that playlist
like months earlier
and I was just laying in
my bed and I was like,
"I'm gonna take all of my
favorite Merle Haggard songs
and I'm gonna make a playlist."
And so without, we know all
of his discography so well
that like without even listening to him,
I could go album by album
and just pick the songs
that like are just magical.
That's what I called the playlist,
Magical Merle.
Oh, that sounds like something
we would have written on a cassette.
Exactly.
In 10th grade.
And you know what? I never
listened to the playlist.
And then when we went skiing-
You never listened to that playlist?
I never went back and listened to it.
And it's probably been nine
months since I made it.
And so when we were coming back down,
we skiing with the boys
and then we were driving
back that afternoon.
I got in the car and I was
like, I thought of the playlist.
And I was like, "This will be perfect.
I'm gonna start playing this thing."
And I didn't tell you any of this,
but I started playing the,
I said, "I made this playlist,
this Merle playlist."
And that's all I said,
and I started playing it.
And we drove all the
way down the mountain.
Absolutely beautiful sunset
coming from Big Bear on what's it,
the Rim of the World road.
You actually, for those
of you in California,
you don't come down to
the 330 to San Bernardino.
You stay on the mountain
and go past Lake Arrowhead and stay.
It's called the Rim of the World.
And if the sun is setting-
It's crazy.
It's amazing and once the sun sets-
It's like an incredible route.
You can see like all of Los Angeles.
And then when the light's in,
you know that's the coastline.
And it was so beautiful.
And to me, it was the,
the boys were on their phones
or falling asleep in the back.
Exhausted from skiing.
And it was a flashback to
when we were in high school
and we would just sit there in the car,
drive around aimlessly, and
listen to these Merle mix tapes
that we would make for each other.
And it was a pristine moment.
And at a certain point,
we get down the mountain,
you fell asleep a little
bit, you wake back up,
the playlist is still going.
We're like, we're not
really talking that much,
but when we were, we were usually talking
about the music.
About Merle.
Which is what we would do.
And it had been, I mean,
it had been so long
since we had done that.
It was like, I just remember
thinking, "This is perfect.
This is a special friendship moment."
And we got back to my
house where you had parked
and we were gonna part ways,
and it was basically
the end of the playlist.
This is when it got back
to like the '60s stuff.
Yeah, stuff that I
wasn't as interested in.
So the playlist came to an end, basically.
It was perfectly timed for this
trip. I didn't even know it.
And at the one point
where like you woke up
and it was still going and
we were talking about it
and you said, "Send me this playlist."
But you didn't.
I gotta tell you,
I realized at that moment
that that is my love language.
Making playlists?
No, somebody saying unprompted,
"Hey, what is this?"
And it's happened a couple other times.
They're like, "What's this
music that you're playing here?"
I was like, "Oh, it's a playlist I made."
And then a few days later, get a text.
"Hey, can you send me
that playlist you made?"
That is my love language.
So you're a DJ.
So yeah, I'm a DJ.
I mean like really you
missed your calling.
You shouldn't be a hair
stylist. You should be a DJ.
But the tie to the fact that like,
without either one of us talking about
what I'm saying right now,
like to me that was your way of saying,
"Hey, this resonated with me.
This means something to
me too. This took me back.
Send me that playlist."
Yeah, because the Merle
discography is so big,
I just find myself,
there's like a couple of albums
that I'll bring up on Spotify,
and every single playlist
that people have made on Spotify sucks
because they always put
"Okie from Muskogee"
as like the first song.
There's two reasons I
haven't sent it to you.
People don't understand Merle Haggard,
like 99% of people who like
him don't understand him
is my contention.
But we do, and it's something
special that we had.
That's right.
And that we relived in that moment.
So hey, it was a very special moment.
It was very special, but it
would be even more special
if you would just send me the playlist.
The reason why I didn't send it
is 'cause I'm thinking
about tweaking the order.
But the other reason is-
Well, you could tweak the order
and just keep sharing it with me.
It'll update automatically.
Okay, that's true.
I wanted you to ask me again
because it made me feel
so good when you asked me.
I was like-
That's a little selfish.
Yeah, it was.
All right, I'll send it to you.
And you know what? I will
also share it with you.
I will tweet it out.
So go to my Twitter. It'll
lead you to my Spotify.
I'll tweet it out.
And then if it changes over time,
it's 'cause I'm adding, I'm optimizing it.
Magical Merle.
Number six, right?
Yeah. What's your number six?
Number six is Flight of the Concords.
Oh, I didn't think about them.
Really?
Yes.
Okay, this is great. Glad you did.
Okay, so if you're not familiar
with Flight of the Concords, I'm sorry,
but this is Brett and Jemaine.
Jemaine Clement who,
lots of people call him Jermaine Clement,
but it's Jemaine Clement,
which I guess is a Kiwi name.
So these are New Zealanders
that are kind of in the,
Jemaine has gone on to become an actor
that you would recognize
from many different movies.
You might recognize Bret
from "Lord of the Rings:
Fellowship of the Ring"
as an elf, but just as a very brief cameo-
I mean he won an Oscar
for writing the music for the Muppet-
The Muppet movie, yeah.
So he's kind of gone into
the songwriting thing
and I think Jemaine is
more doing the acting thing
and producing thing.
Jemaine is a co-creator of-
"What We Do in the Shadows."
So Jemaine was in "What
We Do in the Shadows,"
and so he's collaborating
with Taika Waititi
who didn't make my list,
but is an honorable mention.
Ooh yes.
I love Taika, but he's
more of a recent influence,
and I only know about
him through Jemaine, so.
And that comedic tone, that Kiwi tone
is something that it just blew us away.
It just is like nectar into my mouth.
But obviously you-
I just love it.
Yeah, so "What We Do in the Shadows"
is probably my favorite
television show comedy currently.
But the specific thing,
so Flight of the Concords
is the two-man band
that Bret and Jemaine formed
probably right around the
time that we were coming up
and trying to get our comedy going.
I specifically remember-
Early 2000s.
MySpace?
Well, no, I remember being on a trip.
Oh.
A Campus Crusade for Christ
trip that we were going on,
like probably 2002, 2003,
where we're traveling around
doing our little comedy show
that's really just an
evangelism training seminar
for Christian students.
But we have funny songs that turns out-
We had a lot of funny songs.
Weren't nearly as funny as these two guys.
Well, and I remember
being in a hotel room.
Yes, I remember this.
Turning on HBO,
and all of a sudden there
was these two dudes singing.
It's a standup special,
but it's two guys on a stage
and they're singing songs.
"Business Time" is probably the first one,
which is a song about having married sex
and it's incredible.
And I was just
immediately like-
Married sex.
"Oh gosh, these guys are
so much funnier than us."
Like I was shot in the gut.
Yeah, this has happened
so many times in my life
where I feel like I'm doing something
and then I see somebody
who's actually doing
what I've think I'm doing.
And then I see it happening,
I'm like, "Damn it, I'm not doing it.
I'm not actually that good at this."
Yes, when we did, we look at each other
and almost thought we had to turn it off.
We didn't turn it off. We
watched the whole thing and then-
I hated them. I loved hating them.
We just couldn't talk,
we couldn't talk about it
'cause they were so good,
but it was so, so it wasn't
inspiring, it was challenging.
It was infuriating.
It was sobering.
Yeah, and I would say that
every effort that we've made
in musical comedy over the years
has been an effort to
emulate them on some level
without completely biting what
they're doing, what they did.
Oh yeah, every line has a comedic effect.
There's no filler and they
each have a character.
And so we were students of what they did
and this was all before
the HBO series came out
that was an adaptation
of their first album.
Yeah, which had like a music
video. It's the reason-
It's obviously influenced "Buddy System"
and that there's music videos-
It's the reason
that "Buddy System" has a music video
in every single episode.
But the thing I'll say is-
We actually went in a, we
calculated our comedy songs
like as we were an audience on YouTube.
As visuals.
That, and we specifically talked about
how not to be compared to them
by doing things differently
so we wouldn't just seem
like a hack rip off.
Like basically just avoiding like guitar,
funky white boy music kind of thing.
Or Kiwi accents.
Yeah, yeah.
I have a recurring dream of meeting one
or both of them over the years
and it's like it's an anxiety dream.
Oh yeah. Because you know
they don't know who we are.
But the thing is is that
when I listen to our music,
and again, we don't do a
lot of comedy music anymore.
It's like we can only have,
there's only two of us.
And they don't do it anymore really.
I mean, they're doing it individually,
but when I listen to our music,
anything that we've created,
I always find fault with it.
And this is any artist I guess.
But like I listen to
our music and I'm like,
"Yeah, well, I'd love to
rewrite that right now.
Oh, I'd love to make that actually funny."
But I always, and in my mind,
I'm never not comparing
it to what they did.
The moment of discovery of that special
with like no point of reference at all.
We turned it on.
It just was on HBO.
Two guys sitting on stools, playing music,
doing the exact same thing we were doing.
I was like, "Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa. What's happening here?"
It was really surreal.
My number six is David Letterman.
No.
So what number did you
put David Letterman?
'Cause I know you put
Letterman on your list.
Number one.
Oh, I stole your number one.
I knew this was gonna happen.
I knew he would be on your list
and I knew that he wouldn't be number one.
All right, say what you will.
I think he's more of an,
I think you watched more Letterman than me
in you stayed up later than I did.
Well that I still do.
And you watched, so you
watched more Letterman.
Okay, so again, this was a struggle
because David Letterman is not an artist
in the strict sense, right?
He's a late-night show host,
but this for me is kind of embracing-
I don't know,
I disagree with what you
just said, but go ahead.
Well, no, no, I'm saying that
I do believe that it's an art,
but what I'm saying is
that it's not a traditional
artist category.
It's not a musician. It's not a filmmaker.
It's not a TV show
runner. It's not a writer.
It's a guy, it's a personality.
But the reason that he's my number one
is because in the same way that my dad
sort of serves as this
foundational influence
as the things that I find funny
and the way that I end
up being funny naturally
is very influenced by
the disposition of a guy
like David Letterman.
I've actually come off of that quite a bit
in the past probably five or six years,
just as people's tastes
in comedy has changed.
So the dry, he had a dry delivery
and it was kind of a
knowing slyness to it.
Well, and most people, if you're younger
and your only experience with
Letterman is the CBS days,
and specifically like the
last three to four years-
Grumpy Letterman.
You would just be like,
"This is a angry guy."
This is a guy who's not
happy, who's kind of mean,
doesn't seem to like anyone,
doesn't seem to like himself.
I think that's how the younger
generation responds to it,
and if you look at some of
the way that I kind of behaved
in some of our earlier content,
you might come to the same conclusion.
It was a calculated thing.
I was like this is the
role that I'm playing.
And as I realized that a lot of people
who enjoy internet
content are not into that.
They don't want to see somebody,
they don't like meanness
and they don't even really
like slyness as much.
So I'm a lot more jovial of a guy
in terms of my comedy at this point.
But if you go back to his earlier stuff.
Well, he was kinda like
that. He was that way.
But the reason he's my number one-
He was smilier and he was silly too.
Super silly, and it wasn't-
It was a strange
combination. Silly and dry.
Yeah, well the reason he's my number one
is because for better or worse,
the thing that we are,
and I am most known for
is being one of the two hosts
of "Good Mythical Morning."
Like again, at the end of my life,
the thing that will
have had the most impact
in the entertainment world
will be all these episodes
of "Good Mythical Morning" that I've made.
And I approach
the way that we think about that show
and the way that we embrace
both some kind of structure
that is presentational,
that feels kind of traditional,
that feels like a television show
in a way that a lot of
YouTube content doesn't feel.
That's a huge part of "Good
Mythical Morning's" consistency,
reliability, and sort of point of view.
But the other piece of it is
this unhinged completely
just silliness, just
a embrace of silliness
to the point that it gets weird.
He did a segment called Will It Float
and it was just taking an object-
Yeah, he did.
Putting it in water and then describing
if it was floating or not.
Yeah, and he incorporated
his mom into his content.
The reason that we have our parents
in our content in that way,
he would call his mom and
talk to her on the phone.
He did these, if you go
back and look at the bits,
now there's a really good book about this.
Yeah, can you Google
the Letterman biography?
'Cause we read it. We
got Stevie to read it.
It was like, I mean,
it reminded us stuff I
had actually never seen,
but like the ethos of
"Good Mythical Morning"
is much more like the early
and successful Letterman "Late Show"
than it is "Wayne's World."
I will say that.
Oh yeah.
"Wayne's World" not on our list.
Oh yeah, yeah.
And you kind of fell in more
of that Letterman thing.
Just tell us when you get the...
But for me, I think of you
as more of a Letterman type
and then I kinda like
my comedic sensibility,
I don't know, I don't know who that is.
I think I can see more of
Letterman and your dad in you.
I actually have a hard time seeing,
and I don't have anybody on my list
that's like that version from me.
Don't say Paul Shaffer.
Hey, that was a joke. I
knew you wouldn't say that.
Don't say Don Knotts.
I mean, I do think
that like Dana Carvey is a type,
not just because you look like him,
but I think there is a...
Is that it?
Yeah, Letterman the last guard of-
The last giant.
Last giant.
"The Last Giant of Late Night."
And if I recall, this book
is also pretty honest.
He's a complex character.
He did a lot of things that he regrets,
that obviously I do not
endorse everything that he did
as a person or even everything
that he did comedically.
But I watched so much Letterman
with Ben Greenwood growing
up, Ben Greenwood and I.
And Ben Greenwood, again,
I guess in some senses
Ben should be on the list
because Ben was the one that
was really into late-night TV.
My dad was not into late-night TV.
My dad was not into that kind of comedy.
He also didn't stay up that late.
But Ben would be like, "We're
gonna watch Johnny Carson."
And he's like, "Oh,
and when we really want
something really silly,
we're gonna watch Letterman."
And we watched Letterman on NBC.
The dude was sitting
there with his curly hair.
"The Late Late Show" or
whatever it was called.
Tennis shoes.
And he would just do,
watching an adult do such stupid stuff,
it's really made us who we are.
And the parallels, yeah, from the book,
he was a weatherman and he like had this,
and then he moved into
being a comedian and a host.
He took a circuitous
path to entertainment.
So just like we did, he had
an interesting relationship.
Well, he had a relationship
with his producer,
like they were together for years.
And she's very instrumental
in the book too.
So it's like, that's an interesting thing
that there's like a Stevie
as producer kind of thing.
But not as a relationship.
Not as a relationship though.
But like, there were an entire episodes
where she would trick him.
Like, it would be a joke on Letterman.
Like he wouldn't-
He would get mad.
Yeah, he would get mad, but
it would be live to tape, so.
There's a lot of stories there
that were like we related to,
and that make that very formative.
So I don't know if I
accepted Dana Carvey or not.
I know I look like him and there's a tone,
but he's a character actor, so.
I think I'm just talking about the-
He never played himself.
You're not gonna like
the word zany, right?
You don't like the word zany.
But if you're like, "Okay,
this guy or this guy,
who's the zanier one?"
Well, it's like-
Well, you know what I'm saying?
People are gonna pick you.
If there's the dry and
then if the opposite's wet,
it's like, "Okay, I'm the
wet guy, you're the dry guy."
Yeah, but I don't know
exactly. I'm curious.
You can #EarBiscuits,
let us both know who else
if you're a student of comedy.
I think there's a big-
Beyond just who I look like.
There's a distinction.
And who Rhett reminds you of style wise.
Again, this is an oversimplification,
but the thing that we say quite a bit
is that I'm usually funny on purpose
and you're usually funny on accident.
Now that's an oversimplification
because a lot of your
accidental humor is purposeful.
It's a different mode.
You don't know what's gonna
come outta your mouth.
You don't know exactly
what's gonna happen,
but you go into a sort of
like a trance-like state.
I mean, "Good Mythical Evening"
obviously is the perfect example of this.
But it's like-
It wasn't a trance, but yeah.
It's more chaotic.
Yeah.
It's chaotic, which is great.
And that makes me think of a Martin Short,
but I didn't watch a lot of Martin Short.
So it's not, I'm not
actively emulating somebody
and I can't identify them.
But actually that's really good
'cause if you watch "Only
Murders in the Building,"
which I did, and I enjoyed it.
It's not my favorite, but I enjoyed it.
I am the Steve Martin.
You are the Martin Short.
All day long, without a doubt.
If you have to put us into
that duo, that's how it tracks.
I think that works.
Yeah, I think that works.
But we're still open to
others, #EarBiscuits.
Sorry to steal your number one.
Yeah, that hurts. Just like that playlist.
My number, so now we need your number six,
no, your number five.
My number five,
you already stole that
as well, Ross McElwee.
Okay, my number five is "Seinfeld."
That's my number two.
Oh God. Okay.
Yeah, and I'll just-
I'm really interested
what your top three are gonna be now.
For "Seinfeld," I just boiled it down
to like the relatable observational humor
is something that became
a cornerstone of how-
Anything we write.
What we would build to connect on YouTube.
But it was instinctual
because we were so
obsessed with that show.
I actually put "Seinfeld"
slash Larry David
as one thing, right?
Yeah, yeah, you got to.
'Cause Larry David was the
one that was really fueling
the writing of all that stuff.
I mean, obviously
"Seinfeld" was very much,
it was coming from his standup,
which was super observational.
"What's the deal with this?"
But bringing it into the real world
and into a real conversation,
Larry David is a genius at
that and obviously he does it,
it's on display in "Curb Your Enthusiasm,"
which I love as well.
I think the thing that-
He's the George Costanza
character in "Seinfeld."
The thing that it so resonates
with me as a writer, right?
And that's why I put them at number two
because if I start thinking about,
okay, you got these two
people in this scene
and we need to accomplish this plot wise,
but they need to get there
in an entertaining way,
so they need to be having
a conversation about this.
Well, the way that Larry David
sees conversational humor
is it's the same thing that,
it comes from this tendency
that's in both of us,
which is, hey, we just hung out with,
you were just talking about
it on the last podcast.
We just hung out with this
guy. Let's talk about that hat.
Let's pick him.
Let's talk about the hat he had on.
Look, did you see what he was doing?
Did you see what he was doing
with his left hand and his nose?
Explain that to me.
Right, and it's nothing in "Seinfeld."
There were no jokes. It
was not joke oriented.
It was conceptual, conversational.
And so it very much is
how we like to write.
And it gets very specific and it gets,
it's like, oh, you
typically wouldn't think
that we should be having
a conversation about this
or this is where the humor
should be coming from.
It feels like
I don't even know how to
articulate it very well.
But when I watch
and the only way I really
watch "Curb Your Enthusiasm"
these days is like on TikTok.
I hate to say it.
Oh, I gotta get in on that.
A clip will just come up,
whether it's on the "Curb Your
Enthusiasm" actual account
or just somebody has reposted it.
And I'm just like this moment
where something happens
and I'm just like, "Ah man,
this is like, that's so great."
So that's your number two?
Yeah, you've taken my one and my two.
What's your four?
Coen brothers.
What we were just talking about
made me realize that they
weren't on my list, but yeah.
The Coen brothers are not on your list?
I just forgot.
I just forgot. But yeah,
it's that same thing.
It's a different, it's
character driven comedy,
which we've talked about before
is another big part of like what,
finding ourselves really
loving their comedy
and then trying to figure out why
and having conversations about it.
There's so much about the
Coen brothers I can say.
One, they're a partnership, right?
Which is obviously very relatable to us.
There's a creative evolution
over the course of their career
of them like trying something
and you see these like glimmers
of it in like "Blood Simple"
in which we would like,
we kind of went into
our like Coen brothers
like film study, kind
of our version of that.
"Let's go watch 'Blood Simple'
and make ourselves like it."
Right?
And then you get what I
think is the, just for me,
maybe for you is just
quintessential perfect expression
of them as filmmakers is "O Brother."
That's where it gets into
this thing that is the humor,
the music, the characters.
Everything just lines up
in a way that they're,
and they basically just
hit it out of the park
every time now as far as I'm concerned.
I mean, there's a couple, couple times
where I'm not quite is
into the subject matter,
I don't quite relate as much.
We talked about this on
the our top 10 films.
It's kind of there's that overlap there.
They're so aspirational
because what they do it,
they do so well.
And I think, again,
underneath everything
that we've accomplished
has always been this
desire to make movies.
And I still wanna do it, and
yes, we have written one.
And I just don't think
I'm ever gonna let go
of that desire to be a filmmaker,
not instead of, or in place of what we do,
but in an addition to what we do,
because there's just something about
the way that you can bring
all this creative energy
into a time and place over the
course of a couple of hours
and you can get it done
in a year or whatever
from start to finish.
There's just something so
attractive about that process.
And when I think about
how that's ultimately
sort of the white whale for me personally
of like that that's last
one I'm always chasing
is I wanna make that movie.
They are the embodiment of it
having been done perfectly.
My number four wouldn't
have been on my list,
except that like in a recent conversation,
I was reminded of them.
John Boy & Billy Big Show.
Oh wow!
I thought about them for
a second, and yeah, yeah.
Well, because-
I didn't put them on.
You know like in high school
we were listening to their morning show,
still going to this day,
but it was, they were a duo that was,
they were radio personalities.
So it was conversational
and you'd be with them
for like, for summer,
like on the job with my
dad like painting houses,
we would listen to it in the truck.
We'd listen to it while we were painting,
I would listen to the
whole three or three hours
every single weekday.
And they'd come back
from commercial and say,
"All right, we're gonna call so and so."
And it would be the different,
they would have sketches
where it was like they were
playing different characters,
but it's like you had this keen awareness.
Well, I don't know if I knew at first,
but eventually I wised up, I was like-
They were playing them.
These two guys are beating everybody.
These people aren't calling in.
I'd have comedians come in and guess,
but they had their own world with,
it was like, self-contained that was,
and you became a part of it.
And like you got to know them as people.
And I think that we
have this understanding
of the audience experience
for "Good Mythical Morning"
and for this show,
because we had that experience with them.
That's why it was so thrilling
when they, like I said,
they invited us to
once we started making those viral videos-
We got to be on the show.
The commercials,
we got to be on the show.
And I took my dad there
and John Boy took us to his
ranch, his like farmhouse.
And like, we hung out
and stayed the night.
I actually got a text from Carl.
Carl the cook?
Yeah, he went to my old-
The guy who made their barbecue sauce?
Yeah, he said, "I'll send
y'all some barbecue sauce."
The guy who got drunk and said,
"Man, you has anybody ever told
you you look like a falcon?"
You did, your face looked like a falcon.
I couldn't figure out
how to get in touch with him because-
Falcon, man.
It went to my like Google number
and it's like it couldn't,
but we gotta get in touch with him.
I mean the more you talk about it,
the more I realize-
But all character work
and the sketch work.
So much of that influenced-
And it was audio. It was
like what we did as kids.
We would do radio shows
and it went on tapes.
It really influenced a
lot of the characters
that we created in the early days.
The redneck character.
The redneck guys.
Which had like all different,
we had an array of them.
And when you talk about
just the amount of-
Y'all keep them straight up there.
Actual exposure to a potential influence.
We just, I mean, you that's what you did.
You turned on John Boy and Billy
on the way to high
school every single day.
Yeah, so it's like we
absorbed their sensibilities.
And we got to know them
as real people too,
so you saw both sides of it.
All right, I think I've wiped you out.
No, I have one more. My number three.
All right, what's your number three?
I think I know what,
I know someone that's in your top three
that is on my honorable mentions,
but I'll let you say it.
But my number three is Weird Al.
Okay, Weird Al is my number two.
Okay, I mean, so you get
to talk about him first.
I regret when Weird Al
came on "Good Mythical
Morning" that we didn't like-
Worship him. Worship him.
Give him offerings.
Give him some like a burn offering.
The first cassette tape we
both ever owned was Weird Al
and I still have mine.
I wish I would've brought it
that day and had him sign it.
We should have him back on the show.
We should, we should.
That was during GMM 22
where it was so hectic
that it was like, "Oh, Weird Al's here?
I don't really have time to process that."
He's playing his accordion on the show.
Yeah, but there's also like a woman
who looks like a stripper.
I, like, what?
It was a strange episode.
What was, I don't even-
It wasn't all about him
and it was a disservice
to the great Weird Al,
number two creative influence on my list.
Because I got engaged
with this comedy music
and it just like made the most sense.
Like I wasn't even a music
fan before that, really.
Like I wasn't, because my
older stepsister liked music
and I wasn't gonna like
anything she liked.
Until Weird Al-
Brought you out of music.
I was like, she is, I mean, he is so,
this is, this just totally makes sense.
It was like it was tailor
made, tailor made for us.
And it's strange that like
I didn't know on every one of his albums,
I didn't watch his movie.
So it wasn't like I was a super fan,
but at such a formative time in our lives
when we were like really hitting it off
and like making those dumb
tapes that we were making.
We weren't writing songs together yet,
but it was just like that stuff,
it's foundational in terms of comedy
and obviously starting our career
as musical comedians for the most part.
And one of the first things really
apart from some of the things
that we did in high school,
and then a couple of the
videos that we made in college,
the first thing that we did
together as a comedic duo
was comedy music.
It was those first couple
of Christmas conferences.
Oh no, I'm talking about like,
you're down with Halloween,
like rewriting the words.
Yeah, yeah, that's true, that's true.
Rewriting the words
and getting up on stage
at the fall festival.
But anytime that we were performing.
Yeah, so we did it there,
we did it in middle school.
But then in college,
performing in those Campus Crusade things,
it was just like, "All right,
we're gonna get up there
and we're gonna do this funny song
about the unibrow or whatever together."
And it was, our voices kind of went into
a sort of nasally, Weird Al place that-
Kind of nerdy.
People talk about a lot of our early stuff
sounds very Weird Al-y.
And that was,
it was because we had
listened to so much Weird Al.
It was just, it was in our bones.
Okay, so that was my
number two, that was your-
So yeah, so I've taken my two,
you've already taken my two,
this Seinfeld Larry David
in one and Letterman.
Right, so I gotta clean it up.
My number three-
You have three more?
I have two more 'cause
Weird Al's my number two.
Oh.
My number three I put Questlove.
Oh wow.
Like I'm a huge fan
of Questlove.
And just he's a huge creative inspiration
that is a, within the last two years,
a addition to my list.
Of course, he's a hip hop icon
as a member and drummer for the Roots.
He's a band leader for Fallon,
which is the Roots on Fallon.
But in terms of like you talk
about me wanting to be a DJ
and telling that story.
Like it's a product of like me connecting.
You're like looking at me
like you're like shocked or something.
No, I'm interested to hear this
'cause I would not have guessed this.
Just really identifying
like how much I enjoy music
on like an appreciation level.
Of course with our
Merle Haggard obsession,
like way back in the day,
I remember I went to
Heather Wilson's house
and her dad had a magazine.
It was a country music heritage magazine.
And it like talked about like
the best country music albums.
And I was like, I remember thinking then,
I took the magazine, I still have it.
So like back in high
school, it was something,
I was very passionate about country music
as a offshoot of our
passion for Merle Haggard.
But like I go to 11
when it comes to like
the collection mentality
and like the pre-Wiki Wiki mentality
of understanding everything
about country music.
And I started to think I could become
like a country music museum curator.
Like maybe that can be something I'll do.
I remember thinking about it.
That's why I kept that
magazine all these years
and still have it.
And then it was over the pandemic
there was like a rekindling of that,
which led to like the
listening party broadcast
that I did with Britton
and stuff like that.
But it was a result of
like me starting to watch
Questlove's broadcasts on Instagram,
where he would like do DJ sets
and he would start talking about the music
that he was playing.
And it was like, I mean,
he has an encyclopedic
knowledge of all these things.
I'm not a fan of the Roots.
I've never listened to the Roots.
I'm a fan of him in the way-
But they did back us up while we did our
get down with Halloween rap on Fallon.
Yes we did, which is-
But we've been backed by the Roots
on a performance before.
Which was huge.
I mean, that was a career and
friendship high point for us.
But like the fact that
he branches out into
in middle age, he's like
five years older than us,
but he's using everything
from his career to now do,
to capitalize and do the things
that he's passionate about.
So he's writing books,
he wrote a book about creativity
called "Creative Quest,"
which I've read some of.
He executive produces a hip
hop documentary on an AMC
called "Songs That Shook,"
which is amazing.
And now he's nominated for an Oscar
for Best Documentary Film
for "Summer of Soul,"
which is a,
it's like the black Woodstock, basically,
that was never, the
footage was never released.
And he's nominated for an Oscar
for it and he deserves it.
So the way that he's branching
out and engaging everything
that up from a career
standpoint up to this point,
that like he's leveraging is cool to see.
And so it's very encouraging
that like we talk about
the things we wanna to do,
like you were doing earlier,
and it's, I see a guy
like him that's like a,
he's an elder statesman of music.
And he doesn't just do one thing.
He doesn't just do one thing.
He does a lot.
So when we think about our legacy
and we think about the things
that we have yet to do,
those are two different
things but they interplay.
So even if it's something
like us investing
in the next generation of creators
with our Mythical Creator Accelerator,
it's just another example of,
"Hey, we're gonna pay it forward."
But we're still here for
it. We're not retiring.
We got a lot to do.
So yeah.
Questlove.
And I met him.
We met him once.
If I'd have known that you
felt that way about Questlove
when he was playing the
drums for us rapping,
then I would've probably
been more nervous.
I came to grips with it
afterward, I wasn't as-
Okay, it was after.
Yeah, 'cause it was more pandemic related.
All right, so I just have my number one,
which is for both of us.
You don't have any left.
Yeah, but I mean, I gotta...
You want me to guess who it is?
Yeah.
Is it Wes Anderson?
No, I went in a totally
different direction.
'Cause I was like, he was
on my honorable mention,
but I was like, Link loves
Wes Anderson so much,
is gonna put him number one?
But I was like, but as your list goes on,
I'm like that can't be.
Okay, and this is for both of us.
You're not gonna disagree with this,
because again, with
everything we've talked about.
My number one, I'm putting Benny Enzor.
Whoa!
Yes, baby!
Wow. Yeah, okay.
I mean, yeah. I mean it
just didn't cross my mind.
But now that I I've said it-
But in reality, yes.
It totally makes sense, right?
Oh yeah.
Okay, maybe you've heard his name,
maybe you know from the
"Book of Mythicality"
I was talking about him
or all the times we talked
about our high school band,
the Wax Paper Dogz ending in a Z.
It was the '90s.
So Matt Enzor was in our grade.
His younger brother John
was one year younger,
but their dad Benny was,
he played the piano at the
church that we went to.
We always knew him growing up.
He was one of the youth leaders
and also a dad.
A soccer coach.
He was a soccer coach
when my mom got divorced
and me and her moved into our
own places, the two of us,
it was across the street from the Enzors.
Which they still live over there.
So it's like in the small community,
he was very present at church,
at soccer, in the community.
And then at school later on.
That's right, and then he worked,
he was like the guy who in
charge of the detention.
Which I had to go to.
At the high school.
I had to go to detention
and the guy in charge of it
was my keyboard player.
Yeah, so it's like Benny Enzor started,
through the church he
started a cafe for the,
like a coffee shop for-
Yeah, this is your, this is true.
I'm just, I didn't think about it,
but now that you're putting
it all together, yes.
'Cause I know we didn't, besides your dad,
we didn't think of it
in terms of personal
interpersonal relationships.
We talked about it in terms of like
external celebrity influences.
But yeah, he started the
Maranatha Cafe coffee shop
to have Campbell University
students could hang out,
and it was a way for the church
to have to create a space,
a safe space for them to
hang out, listen to music.
There was an open mic night, which then we
as high school students
involved in the church,
we helped facilitate, move chairs around.
We helped renovate the
building and decorate it.
And Benny was a huge
music fan and musician.
He's a great pianist, also played guitar.
And huge Allman Brothers fan from like...
And so he was a hippie.
He kinda, well, he had a hippie vibe,
he had longer shaggy hair.
He didn't look like any
of our other parents.
And he would, he took
all of his old records
and then we decorated the Maranatha Cafe
with all of his records.
So it wasn't Christian music.
It was like '70s albums wall to wall,
that became the wallpaper.
It was like super cool
and it was his baby.
Of course it was because of the-
Open mic night.
The fact that the Maranatha Cafe existed
and there was this, yeah, open mic night.
Open mic night, that was
what gave us the courage
or the opportunity, we
didn't need the courage,
the opportunity to be like,
"Well, of course we're going to perform
at the open mic night."
And that was when Eric
Woodruff had a guitar
and he could play the guitar.
John Enzor had a bass,
he was learning bass guitar.
But he was learning.
He was definitely learning.
And of course Eric was learning too,
but he was the most
proficient at the time.
And I remember the
first song we ever wrote
was about the, ironically,
given specifically my
deconstruction story,
was about creation.
And it was basically about how creation
proves that God exists.
And that it happened in seven days.
Yeah, yeah, and it-
But the reason why-
We made fun of organic soup
and spontaneous life, but it was-
We had to write Christian.
It was horrible.
Oh yeah.
We had to write Christian songs
because to play the open mic night,
you did have to play Christian music.
It was a Christian cafe.
But that's where Benny comes in
because Benny listened to our
creation song and was like,
"Boys, you know if you're really serious
about playing music,
you should probably learn
how to play cover songs.
Like you should learn
how to play other songs
that have been written."
And he was also like,
"And I've got some old songs
that I wrote like 20 years ago
that you could also play."
And so that was the beginning of us.
'Cause again, most people who sit down,
even if you listen to music a lot,
you sit down to write a song,
even if you can play a few chords,
you don't understand song structure.
You don't understand like,
"Oh, there's this number
of measures in the verse
and then there's a bridge
and there's a chorus."
Like there's a structure that it follows.
If you just start
writing, you have no idea.
Benny saw that immediately
and then was like,
"Here's some songs.
Like, hey, can you just look?
What if you just played
'I Can See Clearly Now the Rain is Gone.'
Or "Country Roads.'"
By John Denver.
And it was, that's how
he learned how to sing.
And that's how I learned
how to play the guitar
because it's-
But he also said, "And I
can also be in the band
to help you actually
make this into a thing."
To like keep the beat.
"I'll play keyboard, and
like if you need a beat,
there'll be a beat on my keyboard."
We didn't have a drummer yet.
Early in the day, right?
And we started writing songs.
He brought out, yeah, like
he had all these songs
that he had written in the
'70s, like handwritten,
and he like taught him to us.
And we sang them.
And it was like Allman
Brothers meets John Denver
sung by two guys
who were trying to sound
like Hank Williams Jr.
Right, it was a train wreck.
I think there's a whole other podcast
just about Wax Paper Dogz,
but I just wanna say that like
we threw ourselves into this band
and because there was an adult in the room
who we considered, it
was like he was a peer.
He was John, Matt did our sound
and did all the tech stuff.
But we were a group of peers
and he didn't elevate himself above us.
And we had so much fun. We
threw ourselves into it.
We committed so wholeheartedly to it.
And there's something
about being in a band
that really helps you develop creatively.
We were making thousands
of creative decisions
in every time we would get together.
And so you start to learn to
work with four other people.
And you learn how, you learn
to trust yourself creatively.
And you learn to put yourself out there.
'Cause what ended up happening
is within that first year,
we went from an older
guy giving us his music
and having the drums be on the keyboard
to me and you sitting in a
room somewhere, writing a song.
And we started writing.
We would've never had
the courage to do that
without his influence.
Yeah,
you and I were writing music
for the Wax Paper Dogz together,
writing music and lyrics.
And then the other thing we were doing
is we were making them a little funny.
Like they all had to be like veiled.
Well, some of them were
like overt Christian,
and some of them were veiled.
And some of them started to get funny.
And that's where we-
The only surviving
recording actually is funny,
it's a little bit funny.
It's a racial reconciliation song.
But it has a reference
to professional wrestler.
Right, so I mean, we can get into all this
in more detail later,
but for now, just like we did
in the "Book of Mythicality,"
we're like giving
throwback thanks to Benny
because in a lot of ways,
I don't think we would be here.
Because as creators, he
really fanned that flame
and gave us a sense of
identity as creative people
that translated into what we wore,
the music we listened to.
By the time we went off
to college, we looked,
we have fully embraced like
the '90s alternative thing,
unlike anybody in our high school
and unlike anybody we
associated with in college.
So it wasn't just an artistic thing.
It was a complete identity.
It set up our personalities in some ways
of always feeling like
we didn't quite fit,
but kind of taking a little
bit of pride in that, I think,
to be transparent about it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, that's a good one.
I think Benny will be, I texted
with John not too long ago,
so I'll let him know
that Benny gets the shout out in this one.
Love you, Benny.
Now, okay.
We talked, we went ahead
and talked ahead of time about one thing.
We didn't give any heads up on
who was gonna be on our list.
But the thing that we
had a conversation about
was that if this list was in fact factual,
that we would be each
other's number one because-
So we can be each other's zero.
So we'll be each other's zero.
We obviously the most
significant creative influence
that is embodied in a person
in each of our lives is each other
because we don't do any
creativity for the most part
where we're not directly
consulting with one another
and it's a product of our
collective imagination.
Yeah, I mean, and I'll also
give a shout out to Stevie.
In terms of it's like
she's become a creative soundboard for us
that like we hatch things.
And then we always know that
there's like the next phase
is getting Stevie's buy-in
and like her applying her filters
and first reaction to the
next thing we're hatching.
Yeah, Stevie has been-
And then obviously shaping creatively
everything you see at Mythical
that we're involved in or not.
She's the first filter besides each other
for everything we do.
I wanna shout out
Jessie, my wife, as well.
I tend to discuss that-
I love that we're using
the term shout out.
We're bringing it back.
I wanna give heartbeat props to my wife
because I very rarely think
about anything creatively
that I don't consult her about.
Anything that I write, I
give to her when I'm done.
And even if I get stuck
creatively a lot of times
'cause I do a lot of stuff at home too.
I do a lot of writing at home
'cause I don't have enough
time to do it at work.
So she's been a huge influence.
And also, go back to the fact
that both of our wives were the ones
who sort of encouraged us
to make a creative thing
our profession back in the day, so.
Oh, absolutely.
But yeah, and I'm saying,
so we'll make each other
our zero on the list,
which sounds bad but I think it's good
'cause there's like, there's
not any, at every single point.
I surprised you with the Questlove thing,
but basically there's so much overlap.
It's like 99.9% creative
overlap over so many years
that like we touch so
much that even the things
that we don't touch
in the other person's creative endeavors,
the presence will be felt.
Well, which is why you'll
probably relate to,
I'm just gonna quickly run
through the honorable mentions,
the ones that were in the initial batch,
but then got pushed off.
Wes Anderson, Spike
Jones, Quentin Tarantino,
Rob Reiner, Donald Glover,
Errol Morris, as I said,
The Lonely Island, Taika Waititi,
Robert Rodriguez, the Duplass brothers,
Will Smith, and Werner Herzog.
Okay, all right. Well
let's wrap this thing up.
This has been a long one.
So I guess I stole your
rec, "Sherman's March."
But so let's just make this a double rec,
'cause we mentioned two
things that are really good.
The first thing is Ross McElwee's,
which it looks like
McElwee, M-C-E-L-W-E-E.
"Sherman's March." Great documentary.
I'm sure you can get it
on Amazon or whatever.
And then that Letterman book,
"The Last Giant of Late Night."
I think if you're in a creative profession
and you're just trying to figure out
how to like define yourself creatively,
or you've got a creative endeavor
that you're currently in the middle of,
I think that can be a
pretty inspirational book.
"David Letterman: The
Last Giant of Late Night."
All right. It's been a fun one.
Hopefully you're inspired, your
creative juices are flowing.
Tell us who your creative
influences are, #EarBiscuits.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.